thank you
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where debt is dumb cash is
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people
build wealth two relationships the right
way and getting a career where they can
change their lives and do work that
matters it's a show about your life it's
called the Ramsay show Rachel Cruz
number one best-selling author many
times over Ramsay personality and my
daughter is my co-host today as we
answer your questions about your life
and your money the phone number here is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five starting off this
hour's Rob in Pittsburgh hey Rob welcome
to the Ramsay show
hello Mr Anthony it is a honor to speak
with you you too sir what's up
hey yeah um I was wondering how
um my wife and I can incorporate your
baby steps into our financial planning
um we kind of started off on our own and
then
um we found you so we are trying to just
uh keep that all integrated and
Incorporated
that's awesome so where are you guys at
Rob financially what's your where where
are you guys at just income and debt and
everything
so actually I am going through a job
change right now from the construction
field to uh becoming a financial advisor
oh nice
yeah so we are on one income right now
and that's um roughly 50 000 a year
okay
um we have between my wife and I we have
66 000 in dollar roths
um
we have 90 000 in traditional IRAs
um non-retirement mutual funds we have
about forty four thousand
and cash
um we have about forty thousand as well
okay
um so we have no debt um other than our
house which we are 175. okay
dang you guys are doing great Rob well
done yeah thank you well done
um yeah well the you know the great
thing about your numbers and you guys
doing as well as you've done and being
wise with it is that you know with
within the baby steps you're jumping
ahead many steps uh all the way to yeah
to four five and six
um so continuing yeah to to put money in
your retirement and then looking to pay
the house off will be your next Big Goal
do you guys have kids
yeah so we have two kids we have um two
529 started with for them
um each with roughly five thousand
dollars in it
um but my I had another just little
question about the the mutual funds that
we have that are in non-retirement we
are down roughly 11 right now and my
other question was should we wait for
the market to rebound before we pull
that
um and put it towards the house I I
understand
um that that's the goal um I just didn't
know what being down right now should we
wait for it to rebound or just kind of
put it towards the house now
well you so you've accurately figured
out that baby steps four five and six
you do simultaneously so you have your
emergency fund with the Forty thousand
in cash you're debt free except the
house and that and you're putting money
into your 401k putting money in the kids
529 and then any money we've got other
than that we're going to throw it at
baby step six which is pay off the house
and that brings us to the discussion of
them the mutual fund account with 44 000
at this down eleven percent so you're
exactly you're asking the question you
obviously understand this so you do know
where you are you know how do we
incorporate this you just live the you
find out where you are in this process
and four five and six is fifteen percent
of your income into retirement
addressing kids college and everything
above that that we can find reasonably
with intentionality we put on the house
so I'm gonna put the mutual fund on the
house now
it is down 11 will it rebound yes when I
don't know and you don't either uh by
the end of 23 oh I'd bet big money it
you know rebounds by then but I don't
know I don't know
um here's the thing I figured out if you
follow this process that had so many
people have followed that is so proven
four thousand dollars doesn't matter
okay and that's how much this account is
down
okay I understand yeah if you if you
make a mistake
by pulling the money now and it jumps up
11 in q1
you missed out on four thousand dollars
well four thousand dollars doesn't make
you rich
neither does neither does in either
direction right in other words if you if
I'm wrong if I'm if I'm wrong and you
pull it out now I'm not mad at four
thousand dollars no no but it's not yeah
it's not the definition of Rich okay yes
yes it's not even the definition of a
good car okay
it's it's uh so it doesn't
mathematically the arithmetic of it it's
not an emotional thing or a statement
about wealth it's a it's a math thing
and so does the four thousand dollars
matter mathematically yeah in whether
you become rich or not no it doesn't so
you could do this either way and it's
not going to make you or break you
you follow me
I do um so if you want to wait on the
market wait on the market but I wouldn't
wait too long
okay we do have two cars that are both
paid for worth about sixty thousand uh
with where we're at now would you
suggest to keep them or to get rid of
them I suspect your income is going to
be over 60.
once you get moving here right
right yeah so I mean that's your your
income being 50 is a temporary thing
it's not it's not what your income is
going to be for the next five years if
you told me you're gonna make 50 000 for
the next five years and you had sixty
thousand dollars worth of cars yeah you
got two dead gun much car but if you're
gonna make 120 000
average over the next four or five years
which you are in household income then
yeah you keep those cars so you know
they don't that's not thrown off so what
would I do if I woke up in your shoes
as weird as it sounds I would cash that
Mutual find out today and throw it at
the debt and because I'm just now I'm
going to get on target I'm just going to
be on target I'm going to put blinders
on I'm gonna submit myself to this
program I'm going to do this program
exactly and with intentionality and and
I'm not going to sit and try to figure
out some way to shortcut and ride the
market or something or time the market
I'm just going to get out of debt well
and what's fun Rob is like just go on
ramsaysolutions.com to the mortgage
calculator and start watching even that
forty thousand dollars you know how much
interest you save by paying off your
house early by applying this money to it
and you can watch versus three months
later though even on that it doesn't
matter mathematically it's more of a
thing of I'm going to do this thing pure
and so 11 but damned I'm doing it you
know yeah I mean that's
um that's how I would do it and in other
words here's another way looking at it
what if you had enough in there to pay
off your house
and but the Market's down 11 paid off
completely I paid off in about 30
seconds yep and being no arguing with me
about it yep so why not take the 40 and
go in that direction principle yeah same
kind of mentality but well done Rob yeah
man uh we are going along and we found
you and we decided to do your plan what
do I do I'm like well and then he knows
the plan he knows the plan better than
better than a lot of people yeah so
better than people I've been listening
to you for 20 years and I just leased a
car you know he's not that guy you know
so
um uh it's about a whole life insurance
policy and took out a new credit card oh
my God uh
but I believe everything you say Dave we
have we get those calls I love those all
the time
I love those costs this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
Cruise Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
[Music]
the Ramsey gold planner with George
Campbell Dr John deloney and Rachel Cruz
helps you every step of the way in your
goal planning for 2023 they sell out
every year did they sell out today
today I don't I didn't get word of that
okay they're getting close getting close
yeah you left
just a few just a handful left yeah we
did two interviews I mean George did
today about this so we're right there
okay got some media hits yes yes but
it's great it's a great goal planner
it's not like as one lady said it's not
a flimsy little calendar I was like no
no no no it is a serious
serious planner I'm trying to get your
mother to convert to it
because she uses that flimsy little
calendar from Walgreens yes yes that's a
day at a glance thing or month at a
glance month at a glance thing she's
done that for like 40 years I think I
think it's the same one what is it teach
a old funny nutrients an old me me new
trick yeah but yeah well and and it's
different than just that right like if
you're just wanting just a simple
calendar you could print that off on
Google this is like has content has goal
setting has I mean it helps you through
many areas of your life not just
spiritual part of your spiritual walk as
well everything Financial relational
that's right there's something in there
from Dr John deloney George Campbell
Rachel Cruz every day here it is all
throughout the thing it's a beautiful as
well it is a substantial uh gold planner
it's a year planner and it will guide
you and walks with you through the whole
year and they are very very popular and
they do sell out every year so if you're
looking for a great Christmas gift uh I
would suggest you go and get that like
uh today that would be my suggestion
ramseysolutions.com hit the uh hit the
store and get the get the old gold
planner going there all right Mary is
with us in Toronto Canada hi Mary
welcome to the Ramsay show
hi thanks very much Dave thanks hi
Rachel hello Mary for taking my call
sure how can we help
if you could just want to get some
advice or your advice on some advice
that we had received about a mortgage
and we have a mortgage in first place on
our home and then a line of credit that
we don't have any we haven't taken any
money out but that is in second place as
a mortgage
and we're in a position where we can pay
off
dot mortgage uh coming up soon but the
advice we were given was that we should
keep that
so we have a mortgage of fourth place
line of credit second place and that
would prevent anyone from fraudulently
putting another mortgage on our home by
keeping that
those two first and second place
mortgages where did this advice come
from a banker good bank
a banker told you you should stay in
debt what Mary here's what's sad this is
a particularly ignorant Banker
not only because the advice is ludicrous
but it's asinine let me walk you through
it okay here's the thing let's say you
pay off your house is it different in
Canada let me say this is there any
difference
because she is in Canada so I just want
to throw that out there I I I cannot
imagine that Canadian law allows fraud
okay it's not that it's something no no
no no no no I'm ranchering Rachel I'm
sorry I'm answering Rachel I jumped in
marriage okay so if someone fraudulently
puts debt in your name of any kind
including on your house
it does not stand it gets removed and it
doesn't cost you a thing
you just have to go to the trouble of
removing it
it's not like and having a mortgage on
your house does not protect you
from that
they could still put effective was his
point
do what
it makes it less attractive for somebody
to pick us up yeah well guess what
mortgage fraud is not rampant
in the U.S or in Canada
it is the most it is the most difficult
kind of fraud to actually accomplish for
a crook it's a lot easier to steal
someone's identity and open up a credit
card like light years easier to open up
a credit card in your name than to do
this and so here's what you ought to do
on the basis of this moron's logic you
should go deeply in debt and stay deeply
in debt all through your life because
then you're less attractive to Identity
thieves
that's how ridiculous this is you know
so no absolutely not and uh by the way
don't ask the fox about the hen house
I'm going to ask a banker if I should
stay in that that's like asking a dog if
it's hungry oh my God a hundred percent
of the time you should stay in debt is
what I live for is to put people in debt
and keep them in debt that's what Mr
Banker says oh my gosh yeah no darling
no
it's amazing how they just play on the
on the fear yeah do you know what I mean
like
like that's that's the interesting
that's the best you got
that's the best I mean it would have
been the argument that you keep your
money and put it in an investment that
makes more than your mortgage interest
rate yeah is at least logical and the
argument's sake this one is not even
this one's like fantasy screwed up stuff
I mean no the the number of paid for
homes that get a mortgage placed on them
um fraudulently is approaching zero it
is a very very very small thing and if
you're concerned about that type of
thing you should have Identity Theft
Protection anyway all of you have in the
states we would send you to Xander
insurance I'm not sure they issue it in
Canada but um I can't keep up with what
Canada does but the only reason is I
didn't know if you're going to get into
like mortgage law or like very specifics
that are different fraud is fraud and so
if someone if someone so folks if
someone signs your name
without a power of attorney to anything
and they put your name in debt you are
not liable for that there's zero times
that you're liable for that debt yeah
how okay so how would that happen can we
just like go down that rabbit hole for a
quick second take to happen it's a very
complicated thing and you have to you
have to sign as if you're her
and then you have to record it at the
courthouse on her house yeah I mean it's
a complicated fraud yeah it's very
difficult to pull off because there's
about three layers of stuff you've got
to do very clearly it's not just like a
credit card no it's very easy to do a
credit card yeah yeah I mean
people do the credit card fraud all the
time but right the the mortgage oh look
point eight three percent of all
mortgage applicants are fraud less than
one percent yeah so there you go Mary
that's the applications
and that's not even yeah that's fair
that's not even it was not even issued
then yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
sure it's going to be like 0.0008 yeah
that it actually occurs right yep and so
it's just it's a non-statistical thing
but if you're worried about fraud and
you should be because there's Crooks
everywhere you should you should get
identity theft protection from sender
Insurance everybody ought to have that
we buy it for all of our employees here
all of our team all their MC team
members and some benefit of working here
it's one of our HR benefits and because
we believe in it that strongly because
there's just something all the time if
you haven't noticed or just thinking
call me all the time on my debit card
and go and somebody using yeah which I
so appreciate you in Mexico yeah I'm
down there again but I mean it's golly
it's not so sketchy
uh I do appreciate my bank though
they're very on top of it in that sense
like I do well because it costs them
money oh yeah not you yeah that's why
they're on top of it it's not it's not
they yes they're service oriented and
that's not it's good that they have some
service but it's it's you complimented a
bank well but it's it's really not that
altruistic I mean because it's their
money that's going to be lost not yours
yeah they're trying to protect
themselves by giving you service that's
the thing and you got to keep this
amount of banks but Mary that's a that's
a thing that comes up all the time and
um
the fear of this is all of the internet
yeah I'm just really shocked that a
banker actually came up with this as the
reason to stay in debt among all the
other possible reasons that a banker
could have given this is this guy's
really lame so I mean he's like bottom
fishing here serious but that's the way
it is and I'm glad you called Mary
there's nothing you know Rachel I've
been doing this for 30
almost 31 years coming up on now here
and uh it turns out that 30 years from
now when I'm not here and you're still
doing this the questions will probably
be the same game
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
with health care costs Rising learn how
Christian Healthcare Ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Cruise Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host in the
lobby of Ramsey Solutions which by the
way
you should stop by and see us when
you're out running around and over the
hill and through the woods Grandmother's
house we go for the holidays and all
that stuff come by and see us we've got
a free homemade chocolate chip cookies
free coffee free all kinds of good stuff
over here and a big bookstore and you
can watch the show being done on the
glass every day live from one to four
Central between now and about the 22nd
after the 20 seconds you're gonna get
best doves but you aren't going to come
around here anyway after that so
um but yeah come around see us we've
always got uh 50 to cut 50 to 200 folks
standing around sitting around watching
the show happen every time we do it live
and
um also it's where the debt free stage
is which is where Jerry and Brenna are
standing on the debt free stage hey guys
welcome thank you thank you where do you
live Dixon Illinois all right very cool
welcome to Nashville how much debt have
you paid off 87 000. all right how long
did that take 31 months cool tool and
your range of income during this 99 so
we should be about 135 this year cool
what do you do for a living I'm a
manager for an Ace Hardware rental
department and I sell Power Equipment
like chainsaws and stuff like that cool
and I'm an office manager at Pest
Control consultancy pest company in
Dixon all right very good what kind of
debt was the 87 000. we had 30 000
Consumer Debt some credit cards alone to
our dad a couple cars and then the rest
was our house oh paid off your house
wow good for you you're young to pay off
your household are you I'm 37 33.
look at the weird people yeah I love it
way to go you two very cool what's this
house worth about 150. I love it good
for you very fun how long you two been
married nine and a half years okay cool
but two and a half years ago something
happened oh covid yeah yeah but other
than that uh what happened that uh woke
you guys up and got you on the path here
so it was actually uh December of 2019
it was right after Christmas I had a
dream car in mind and I was entertaining
the idea of I think it's time for Mom to
get a new car and being the wonderful
husband that he is I mean I think he
thought you know this is going to be her
life lesson I'm going to take her she
thinks she's gonna drive it home but
we're not so we went anyways
um and we were actually in a we were in
a seven year term for our vehicle that
we had so we were gonna go upside down
in it
um very casual want the car he goes and
figures the numbers comes back the
payment's going to be more than our
mortgage
um it was a big pill to swallow when I'm
like like wow so we just you know
casually we're like okay we're gonna
think about it
um walk out of there we look at each
other and we're like this is crazy like
this is crazy something has to change
um and we had we had looked into doing
this before we got our DVDs from my dad
years before that but this was the
kicker
um and we got lucky because kovid
happened in 2020 so you couldn't go out
and do much anyway so that was extremely
helpful and that's where it kind of
helped build the momentum so wow
breakthrough Oh by heartbreak too right
yeah I'm gonna go get a new car yeah
there it is yeah I'm a car guy and I
knew doing so many loans back in the day
that I knew we couldn't afford it
anyways but she went so many dealerships
with me I'm like I'm gonna go with her
and just let her experience this yeah
let her see it yeah okay so we're both
of you on board like what did you guys
both leave and look at each other and
say something has to change did one of
you kind of feel it more urgent yeah you
know she always thought the idea of we
shouldn't do car loans but you know then
I brought it home it's my idea let's go
ahead and do this now you know so I was
actually two days before or two days
after Christmas all the videos started
popping back up on YouTube I was working
out and I thought I took it home to her
let's do this you know now it's my idea
so it's a good idea you know yeah
Google heard you get started by feeding
you all the all the content oh that's so
funny okay so for the two and a half
years you said obviously there were
parts that were kind of easy because
it's not like you're traveling and going
on vacation you did it right in the
heart of covet and pandemic and
quarantine and everything so what what
was hard though like because now we're
kind of back to yeah we're back to life
and moving to shaking but you guys still
were doing it yeah I'm doing the plan
for the first seven and a half years of
our marriage we didn't have joint bank
accounts so that was the hardest thing
for me oh yeah stuff in my childhood
just I was tight with my money so I
didn't want to let it go but I think it
was an episode I watched that first
couple days before we started if
somebody came on and said something
about combining your incomes is the only
way to make it work and yeah I went home
and said let's do it let's combine our
income Whoa man they just all in yeah
a lot of couples don't still it's like
it's the pushback we get you know we get
a lot of pushback on different things so
how
you get for me personally yes people
George causes some people not to eat out
and you because join accounts how did it
change your marriage for something to
hate on way better talking about money
yeah so there's way more is more trust
than everything all involved into it so
yeah everything's laid out there's no
secrets which I would say for the most
part there wasn't at that point anyways
but then it's just all right there in
front of you we're like roommates like
you say you know we pulled our money in
and then we just blew everything else
you know we bought our own stuff that we
wanted to on the sides yep yep
congratulations you guys thank you well
done with two kids how was that because
there's a lot of families that listen to
the show and are on that job this one
likes to go out to eat and have fun with
the kids while I'm at work it's kind of
fun he's the fun sponge
do all that so that's hard because we
have a friend that loves to go and do
things and you know when the budget's
gone it's gone and the kids understand
that now too they'll you know if they
want McDonald's how much do we have left
in the food budget can we go oh no not
this month we'll have to wait till it
resets and so they totally grasp it and
understand how it works as well you've
had our daughter in kindergarten her
teacher came out and said she keeps
talking about this Dave Ramsey who's
Dave Ramsey yeah
you know and they know the budget's gone
when does the budget restart so we can
go to McDonald's
that's awesome I'm big in the
kindergarten Democratic demograph's one
of my big demographics
oh my gosh way to go you guys so cool
very very well done hey we got a copy of
The Total Money Makeover for you and the
live and give bundle and the uh baby
steps millionaires book because that's
the next chapter in your story for sure
you're on your way and a one-year
membership to Financial Peace University
if you haven't been through it formally
yet go through it uh if you are give it
all away whatever you want to do it's
the live and give bundle all right bring
the kiddos up and tell us their names
and ages we have Arya she just turned
eight on Tuesday
um Hudson he is five very cool all right
so all the way from Illinois have we
been practicing our debt-free screen we
did watch some old debt free screens on
YouTube before we came down okay so we
kind of got the format okay that's good
A little bit of prep
very fun well the cool thing is is that
they're both old enough to remember that
time that their parents during the
pandemic changed their family tree so
you guys are heroes well done very very
well done I'm looking at uh little kids
whose mom and dads are heroes and change
their family tree it'll never be the
same because of what you all have done
so very very cool beautifully
beautifully played it's good stuff Jerry
and Brenna Arya and Hudson Dixon
Illinois
87 thousand dollars paid off in 31
months making 99 to 135 count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream ready one
two three
[Applause]
that is how it's done ladies and
gentlemen oh man I love it very cool so
sweet very cool yeah really and they did
um man they paid off a lot of debt with
that income in two and a half years yes
yes that's like beans and rice rice and
beans they cut everything completely
focused completely intense which is how
you do it folks and if you don't know
the debt snowball is what these folks
are using it's where you list your debts
everything but your house smallest to
largest debt regardless of the interest
rate you pay minimum payments on
everything but your smallest debt and
you attack it with a Vengeance like your
freaking hair is on fire like your life
depends on it you sell so much stuff the
kids think they're next you're not going
to see the inside of a restaurant unless
you're working there you and your spouse
are locking arms and there is no
freaking vacations no way Winer get her
done you've got to lean in and go
scorched to Earth and knock it out no
just like that call the wambulance and
get it done this is how it's done right
in two and a half years two and a half
years and a half years man I'm telling
you these people were not moseying out
of debt they were running like their
life depend on it and now they're a
hundred percent free house and
everything
very impressive and that ladies and
gentlemen is exactly how you do it this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thanks for joining us America Rachel
Cruz Ramsey personality number one
bestselling author is my co-host today
Steven's with us in California hi
Stephen how are you
good how you doing Dave better than I
deserve what's up
it's an honor to get to talk to you guys
today
um my wife and I recently inherited an
estate from a good friend of ours he was
an elderly man that we took care of for
about 13 years and he recently passed
um and we're just nervous to
navigate the probate process and the uh
the county office that looked over the
will it's a handwritten will said that
we shouldn't need an attorney but we
don't know if we should get one anyways
or or how to navigate it
okay
um what are the what is the size of the
estate
how much money is it worth
well the his bank account was not uh I
was a beneficiary so they said that that
stays out of probate correct so they
they just wrote me a check for that uh
there is a mortgage on the home of about
150 000 still it's worth probably 350
and then he's got a car that's worth
somewhere around ten thousand and just
miscellaneous things other than that
okay
um
so you took the uh the handwritten will
to the county probate department or the
probate office
uh the public affairs office is who
wanted it we haven't we haven't
submitted the probate paperwork yet
okay
and and he has no he has no next of kin
he was a single man
um we were the only ones that he really
led into his life
um you know we were next door neighbors
with them and and everything you know
there's a couple hundred thousand
dollars involved here in equity and
um yeah so what would I do if I woke up
in your shoes
um the fact that it's hand written
doesn't invalidated but it makes it uh
have more potential
bumps in the road
it's not it's not as it's not as
airtight uh necessarily it could be
legally I'm not saying it legally but it
just it it raises the
you know people people uh that you're
dealing with her so I I would talk to a
couple of probate attorneys in that
county and ask them what they would
charge you have you priced the service
of having someone run it through
uh the one attorney I talked to she said
she was going to get back to me and that
was over two weeks ago and she hasn't
called me back yet okay so that means
you're not using her
yeah yeah
um so I mean I wouldn't spend uh two
thousand or five thousand dollars to do
this but I would spend 500 bucks and let
someone else screw with it
um in a heart rate I would do that and
so I would look for some because if it's
if it is as the county Affairs officer
told you if it is a no-brainer for it to
just go straight through it's not a lot
of legal work for the attorney but to
have someone that knows everybody down
at the courthouse in that area that can
just walk down there and walk the thing
through and knows the judge and it's
kind of like going to traffic court at
that point it's just automatic right
versus you walking through there and
have never walked through this land mine
before and do not know where the bombs
are that you could step on that would be
me I don't know how to do that
and so I would personally Dave would
hire somebody to go do that for me so I
didn't just it's work but it's not worth
two or three thousand or five thousand
dollars for something that consists of
three whole assets a bank account that's
already handed off a car and a house
that's mortgaged
um so right no I wouldn't spend
thousands and thousands but I would
spend some money to have someone just uh
that knows the path through the woods so
to speak
sure and then do I keep his um do I keep
his bills current or do I let that go
into the probate process
what other bills are there
uh his his mortgage and that we just
paid his car registration uh we put
insurance on his car because it's parked
outside and we don't want it um
to get destroyed and or stolen and and
you lose the assets yeah I would do
those kinds of things but um and if you
don't pay the mortgage you know you're
gonna have to when you have to catch it
up uh later on so what are you gonna do
with the house
uh we might put a 15-year on it and and
get it paid off quick and rent it
um
what's the interest rate we were
right now
um on that one I think it's
four percent I wouldn't bother to
refinance it I would just pay on it
oh okay just pay extra on it you can pay
extra on a 30 and pay it off in six so
it doesn't matter
so you don't have to restructure it it's
a lower interest rate than markets so I
would just keep it
with being in his name though doesn't
matter
um and being a VA loan doesn't matter
with that oh okay doesn't matter he died
he died the mortgage stays in place as
long as you keep it current that's the
law
oh wow that's good to know yeah the um
the data the standard boilerplate VA
deed of trust does not allow them to
call the note in the event of death of
the veteran
it does it just as long as you keep it
current now if you don't keep it current
they foreclose on it obviously right but
so I would just keep it current and I
would go get an attorney run it through
and then let's get the thing paid off as
fast as you can you got a nice rental
how much more complicated would it be if
he had family that were going against
the will and it's handwritten
oh well all of a sudden you've got
litigation costs now yeah because you've
got
um you know you've got a dispute that's
got to go before the judge and you
probably
I don't know it might be 15 20 000 bucks
now because you got to fight with
because of it's being specific
handwritten like is it no just because
you got to fight if anybody wants to
fight it okay just call me because I'm
just thinking like the problem with the
justice system is it has nothing to do
with Justice it has to do with you've
got to pay to fight even if the other
person has absolutely no cash yeah yeah
I was thinking about like Mama Bear
legal forms how easy it is to get a will
right online and do you know do a
specific will and how much more
complicated it is when you don't have a
will or
you know a handwritten just like they're
in the right dude like it's the how much
it stands up in the legal process it'll
stand up just fine as long as it meets
the exact same guidelines but it does
put it more into question if there's a
dispute because you know what what are
they going to say they're going to say
this guy you know this guy Stephen he
you know my my dad kind of had
Alzheimer's and he went over there and
befriended him and talked him into
writing this thing out by hand and right
it just lends itself more to The
Narrative of some kind of something like
that if somebody wants to argue about it
yes yes um and you're more likely to
have done it wrong
because Wills are State specific and
um I've written handwritten will is
legal in every state but what is
required whether it's a notary whether
it's three Witnesses a witness those are
different in a lot of States yep and so
it's not a blanket federal law that
dictates what a will has to contain to
be valid it is different from state to
state
um and I'm sure California is weird
because California is weird on
everything when it comes to law right
all California laws are weird and the
other one that's really weird is
Louisiana because they're french-based
law rather than english-based law and so
you get all kinds of wacky stuff in
Louisiana too
um and you know and then you've got
stuff like Texas and Florida where they
just don't even have any laws no I'm
kidding but uh
but I was much more Wild West in those
areas so a lot of there's a lot of good
legislation I'm just joking around but
the thing is it is very different and
that's why you need the rest of you out
there listening need to go to mama bear
legal forms but let's just say again
because I don't want to get like 73
lawyers sending me hate mail a
holographic a handwritten will is 100
legal and airtight if executed properly
according to state laws
the only thing that could the only the
only negative about it is or the biggest
negative about it is one you could have
done it wrong because handwritten means
you did not get help usually and you
might not have the right number of uh
Witnesses or whatever two if someone
wants to argue about it it lends itself
more to the argument that's the story
about it yeah that a week old person was
unduly influenced in some way right you
know by the crazy stepmother or the
whatever it is you know the arguments
that people always have so what we
always tell folks to do is get a
professionally done legal will a legal
will for your state for Mama
bearlegalforms.com and then if there are
relatives and this gentleman didn't have
relatives okay but for the rest of you
out there we're just going to use this
as a teaching session here
tell everyone what the will says go
ahead and have a reading of the will
while you're alive so if you're going to
piss someone off when you die go ahead
and do it while you're alive
you're doing cocaine you get nothing
just tell them okay your cocaine hot
habit gets you kicked out of the wheel
just go ahead and tell them now and that
solves it and then when the cocaine
addict shows up once they're cut later
after you're gone it keeps it down the
lawsuits this is the Ramsey chef
foreign
[Music]
hey it's Rachel Cruz co-host on the
Ramsay show if you want to do your debt
free scream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com set free screen we'd
love for you to come to Nashville and
tell Dave your story that's
ramsesolutions.com debt free screen
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where that is dumb cash is
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Rachel Cruz Ramsay
personality is my co-host today number
one best-selling author and my daughter
thank you for joining us open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five hey guys I want to just stop a
second especially this time of the year
and say thank you
to all of you we regularly ask you to
consider subscribing to the show on
YouTube or as on your local podcast your
your version of where you listen to
podcasts and so forth or of course share
it with a friend you can do that with a
link or a text or whatever or if you're
listening on radio Just say Hey listen
to the radio station here's the the time
that the Ramsey show is on and you just
spread the word for us thank you so much
for that and
um we know that you do it a lot because
we just got this thing in from Spotify
this is your podcast was in the top one
percent
of all podcasts in the world shared
so you guys are sharing it so much
telling people about this on on Spotify
in particular that we're in the top one
percent of uh
in the top one percent most shared
globally I'll use their verbiage so I
get it in the right right place thank
you I know thank you for sharing it and
thank you for telling people about this
and we're glad that we're glad that
we're helpful yep and what's fun is on
like Instagram and stuff you get your
top spotify's putting out your top
podcast that you listen to are top songs
or top artists like you get your kind of
your yearly uh top top list and so
there's been so many sending you know
our shows and so yeah it's like the
Ramsey Show it's like Ramsey Show Dr
John deloney show smart money happy hour
virtual Cruise he was like I think I
have an addiction to Randy you know Ken
Coleman show all of them and so those
are all Ramsey Network Productions and
uh they're all of us jumping in and off
of each other's shows is what it amounts
to and uh and this one's kind of the
mothership that you're listening to here
but
um thank you guys thanks for listening
to Dr deloney for smart money happy
hours a big hit
um it is it's uh really really fun
um even for old people I like it
um ah until until
this week and I don't this I don't like
the blind love is thing the reality show
stuff that was a painful
it was a painful episode but you and
George handled it the process well and
your addiction to those reality shows is
a little bit good it's a little bit uh
disheartening but it gives me life it
gives me life
I love it Clarence is with us Clarence
is in Baton Rouge hey Clarence what's up
hey Dan Rachel it's really good to talk
to you and Rachel I have to say that
today uh this week's episode of smart
money happy hour actually endured more
than I thought I would yes thank you
Clarence you're saving me wow you're
experience your love is blind guy
I wasn't until I listened to him Rachel
was so enthusiastic oh she is
enthusiastic you gotta binge it over
Christmas break you just have to be
careful what you're enthusiastic about
out there I'm just saying all right man
how can we help today
sure so um uh you know it's almost
Christmas time and uh we're on baby step
two but my parents said they wanted to
uh pay for the gas money for us to come
home for Christmas because obviously
that wasn't an option
um for us to come home while we're in
baby stuff too and you know there's no
strings attached they don't want us to
get any gifts or anything they just want
us to be home for the holidays with them
uh you know especially want to see their
grandkids and everything so
um I just wanted to hear your advice
about it because I just feel guilty
because I have been you know working the
baby steps getting stuff done but I just
feel like everything's you know my fault
because you know I'm the one that got us
into the debt to begin with and my
parents have helped us out with things
before with you know especially before
we were he's all intense and now that we
are it just kind of feels weird you know
accepting their uh
charity when you know I just want to
kind of just do things and just kind of
Buckle in myself and just get through
the baby stuff
okay so I kind of want to figure out is
this a
um
a little bit of just like a pride thing
or is there a value system that you and
your wife have set this holiday season
and the only reason I asked is I was
talking to Dr John zaloney about this
and about you know setting up boundaries
and like if things are just if they're
crazy like there's a level that you you
know may say no this year
um not necessarily because you can't
financially afford it but just even on
an emotional standpoint of like if
you're just like I just want our
families choosing something different so
is there any level of that or is it just
strictly you feel weird accepting money
from your parents for for gas money but
you guys want to go there
well I I think you uh nailed exactly
what my wife has been saying that she
doesn't want to see a prizing for me of
being just self-reliant
um uh it's more of just like you know
we've been you know working hard towards
it's not like it's gonna negatively
contribute to us it's not going to put
us any further in debt I just you know
my parents have done a lot to help us
over the years and sometimes it feels
weird for me being you know in my late
20s and you know I'm working on you know
various degrees so we're not making a
ton of money right now but
um you know eventually we'll you know
build up our income but it just just
feels like uh I I guess that's why I was
asking to see if it was a pride thing
for me as opposed to just a hey Mrs you
know it is a pride thing and it's not a
bad kind of pride
to just stand up and go you know I I
feel more like a little boy than a man
when I do this and it I don't like it
and that's okay to say out loud okay and
then the weird thing is once you say it
out loud it kind of loses its power
um and so like
um you know we were making uh pretty
decent money we didn't need the money
and when Rachel was a little girl her
Grandpa uh Sharon's dad owned a gas
station and it was kind of tradition
when you went in for Thanksgiving
everybody filled up at the gas station
and it wasn't you know he's like make
sure you get a tank of gas before you
leave them we're like you bet by Paul
especially the cost of gas right now you
know so uh but I I and but it didn't
have it wasn't because we couldn't
afford it that was different or it
wasn't because we were working a plan
that was different but it was still free
money from Grandpa you know kind of
thing uh so I kind of get what you're
saying I think it's a normal feeling to
do this but if I were in your shoes I I
would uh accept the gift and go home and
let them see their grandkids
okay well that's great that's exactly
why I called you guys I think that you
and uh Rachel uh perfect one stand for
this so thank you so much it speaks
highly of your character that you're
struggling with this a little bit
if you let it completely dominate who
you are and keep everyone from having a
good Christmas then it's kind of gone
over the bubble does that make sense
yes it does yeah so I'm I'm proud of you
yeah it's very good man yep accept it go
home for the holidays yeah it's great
yeah and um it's uh uh you know
interesting we talk about giving a lot
and we're doing the giving show on the
14th and if you have a great giving
Story by the way email it to us at ask
at
ramseysolutions.com ask
ramseysolutions.com put giving in the
subject line but
one of the most difficult things about
giving is learning to receive
very hard it's hard for me and almost
can say more about I mean like there's a
level of like struggle with receiving
things
um especially things that are
out of proportion kind of things like
this over-the-top stuff yep that one I
really really really struggle with this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
Rachel Cruz Ramsay personality is my
co-host today best-selling author thank
you for joining us America open phones
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five hey if you procrastinated blue
past Black Friday Cyber Monday we're
extending our Cyber Monday sale we're
here to help for this week only you can
get our best-selling books and tools as
low as five dollars you gotta hurry
these deals will end this week you can
get our quick reads like my latest the
momentum theorem Dr John deloney's
redefining anxiety all under 10 bucks
our number one bundle the starter
special has 77 percent off on it and
we've extended the Cyber Monday sale on
the ten dollar book sale which includes
Ultra three of Rachel's books number one
bestsellers and uh baby steps
millionaires my latest number one
bestseller is ten dollars and Total
Money Makeover all there this is not a
place where you're going to find
inflation as a matter of fact we are
into deflation like recession
apparently I don't know what our problem
is Cyber Monday sale continues all week
long be sure and check it out
ramseysolutions.com our question of the
day comes from blinds.com it's the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings free samples free
shipping and new promos all the time
check it all out they use the promo code
Ramsay when you do and today's question
comes from Rachel in Kentucky our 19
year old daughter just moved out after
paying rent to us for the last eight
months my husband wants to consider the
money as hers and give it back to her
but I disagree currently she has zero
plans to go to college and has moved out
because we made her it was time I was
considering investing some of it or
using the money to pay for college for
our other daughter who will be
graduating high school next year
what's your opinion mom is hard mom core
mom is feisty towards her daughter oh I
bet if it was a son
she'd give him the money oh 100
oh the water on my daughters I feel like
than Charles my little baby boy little
baby boy
um I don't know Rachel let me think
um
it's fine not to give it back to her it
does feel funny using her money to pay
for the other sister's College
um would you give it back to her even if
she has no plans like she doesn't know
what she's gonna be doing
okay there's
something wrong with this situation that
is not money
it was time for her to leave and I'm
going to take her money and give it to
her sister it kind of sounds like we're
a little pissed at daughter I don't know
there's a little friction here hello
between Mom it's time for her to get out
why hey I'm with you kick him out I
ain't got any problem with that part but
um
get out there and do your thing like you
have to give her back the money you
don't have to but don't not give it to
her because you're angry with her for
her behavior and then don't not give it
to her and double down on the punishment
and give it to her sister yeah that's
that's that's a little vindictive is the
way it feels a little bit here so uh by
and large I I think uh so that is kind
of sad though I'm thinking about my two
daughters and if I'm like I'm thinking
you're so mad at one of them you give it
to the other one yeah
it's like you little twerp I'm gonna
give it to your sister
um so yeah I I um
I I think your husband is probably
saying that uh giving your daughter back
this money is not a moral issue it's not
an ethical issue I don't think it is I
don't think you owe it to her
um I think her leaving with a little bit
of friction as she leaves sparks flying
uh as the uh as the old trunk was uh
drug out and thrown in the back of the
car or whatever we call it here
um
this would be just a little Grace um
I'm going to give it to her and just
call it Grace and just put it not to try
to buy her affection or to cover over
the misbehavior or something like that I
don't know what went on
but you you know you said it was time
for her to go so there's something
something a little bit pushy there and
because we made her listen yeah
um uh or maybe uh
she was doing nothing I mean she could
you know what I mean like yeah oh well
so maybe you tie the giving money back
to her based on her behavior some
Behavior you want to encourage out there
in the wild
okay and so like um you know if you do
this or this we'll give you the money
we're going to give you this back or you
know like for instance and you know
honestly I kind of think Mom's pretty
upset whether there's a lot of emotion
in these words and I think probably mom
you step back and just ask your husband
to talk to her about it to the daughter
about it and uh because there seems to
be a little bit there and just say you
know we I think we might uh we might
want to help you in your new start
um and if you like went through match or
something if you match your emergency
fund or will
um you know or if you're gonna pay if
you're gonna pay off some debt we'll
help you with that and we'll match that
up you know we're gonna use some of the
money you paid us in rent to help you
get started and to encourage some good
behaviors if you want to go through
Financial Peace University you know we
would give you a thousand dollars of
this back as an incentive to do that and
something like that something that helps
the the daughter that left get our get a
sustainable situation out there but now
I would not give it to her if she's
misbehaving out in the wild yeah and
you're going to finance her misbehavior
by giving her rent money back that's not
an act of love that's just enabling so
um yeah I so I I guess there's a lot
going on here that we don't know but
um
we are sure mom's hardcore no question
and I like her that's great because they
uh you know an eagle that doesn't leave
the nest is eventually known as a turkey
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five triple eight
eight two five five two two five you
know I found that line was when you and
I did that book smart money smart kids
oh yeah your first number one we were
talking about kids leaving the nest in
that book and you know in researching
that book and trying to put verbiage to
some of the stuff that we did in our
family and that we've taught other
families to do on teaching their kids
how to handle money that's when that
line came up and that's how long I've
been doing that it just occurred to me
that's where that's coming from yeah all
right James is with us in San Bernardino
California what's up James
hey how's it going Dave uh Rachel Merry
Christmas God bless you guys everyone
around the solutions how you guys doing
Merry Christmas same here how can we
help
um I want to know if I am taking a ride
on the rambulance board if I'm being
reasonable
um
my wife and I are
about to finish baby step three because
I would put us in baby step 3B
but prior to that
I'd like to buy a car I want to save up
for it pay for it in cash because I have
one vehicle in my family and it's a
salvaged title Toyota Camry and I want
to know if prior to babysat 3B is saving
up for the car is reasonable sure
absolutely that's exactly where you do
it
perfect I was like James
now the the thing is obviously you know
what are the guidelines on cars you tell
me
James
um
I mean I'm thinking I'm thinking or used
Toyota
something I and I correct me if I'm
wrong I think it's
oh my god I've been listening to you for
four years David
I'll put you on the spot to give you a
text quiz Dave Ramsey take no James you
did not fail you didn't know you needed
to study no Dave just tell him the
answer so no more than half your annual
income in total cars the other car is
the Camry with a salvage title
yes sir
yeah but it's not worth much okay and
what's your household income
uh household income is about 160.
excellent you do need some cars you need
two cars
yes sir yeah you're driving uh the
cameras on its last leg and you got no
other cars right
no other cars and I'd like to buy a RAV4
something all-wheel drive I can't buy an
electric car like Rachel oh it's okay
James not everybody can be not everybody
can be Rachel in Georgia
um no RAV4 is great that's a great car
yes getting but yeah you're talking
about a reasonable car you guys make
great money so what are you gonna spend
on it
um
I I mean I'm in California everyone
wants uh EVS out here I still like me a
combustion engine I'm thinking 20 okay
25. all right and where are you going
what are you going to spend on the other
car because you gotta buy another one
too
I mean this one still works all right I
think you need to move up a little I
move up to about a ten thousand dollar
car probably
um it's well within your budget and you
need them this time you've gotten the
emergency stuff behind you one two and
three is the Hardcore gazelle intensity
now you are moving from intensity to
intentionality you make 160 000 a year
you don't have to drive a piece of crap
if you save up and pay cash for it this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of Ramsey Solutions on the
debt-free stage Jarrett is with us hi
Jared how are you I'm living the dream
how are y'all better than we deserve sir
welcome where do you live Atlanta oh
cool welcome to Nashville and how much
debt have you paid off Jared 37
271.94 cool and how long did this take
19 months good for you and your range of
income during that time uh started at 52
000. I made a job change gotta raise uh
promotion uh took on some side Geeks and
now it's over 60. good for you what do
you do for a living I'm a healthcare
marketing specialist at Healthcare I.T
company great good for you cool what
kind of debt was the 37 000. uh so
student loans it was a credit card and
then a loan I took out to pay off
another credit card of course yeah of
course yeah real Financial Mastermind so
what what happened 19 months ago got you
started on this Ramsey Way so um when I
graduated from college in 2016 my one of
my mentors my saxophone teacher was
telling me hey you really need to pay
off your debt start investing Building
Wealth and I was like great I'll I'll do
that I did not do that and then I went
to work with her his wife and she was
doing the same thing so for four years
they were just pounding this into me and
I just I think I like set an arbitrary
goal like okay I'll try to be debt free
by the time I'm 30.
um January 2020 rolls around oh um I was
like okay I'll try to pay off the car
this year and I was like I wasn't even
Dave ish I was on like the Lacroix
version of Dave like just just no
substance at all the horrible tasting
water version of Dave yeah so
I I did pay it off that year and the
next month when I should have started
paying off another debt I was like okay
I've been good I can treat myself a
little bit this month and then I'll get
back on it next month and then so I paid
off six thousand dollars on the car but
I replaced it with six thousand dollars
of credit card debt of course and I
remember waking up at the end of the
year feeling just horrible I mean I was
like I have all that I should have all
this money but I don't and I got a
Christmas bonus for my job at the time
and I know I had to just put it all on
the debt and I was like this should be
my money like I hate waking up like
every every day feeling like this like
this I have this weight on my chest and
I just snapped and I was like maybe it's
time to finally listen to to Chris and
Kenyon who were telling me all these
years to actually do this and start
getting out of debt and Building Wealth
that's amazing well and you lit I mean
and you did it in 19 months 37
000 making 52 to 60. so you did I mean
you sacrificed I did that's a lot yeah
it was a lot of cutting back on stuff
yeah I went from eating out every couple
of every like several times a month
um to going okay I have a coupon for a
free Taco in the Taco Bell free Taco yes
that I split with with Julie my partner
that was our date night but I sold a lot
of stuff I picked up um I play saxophone
as well so I picked up some gigs uh I
dog sat for my sister I helped a public
speaker friends do his present do his
materials I was supposed to also chicken
sit for my dad when she was on vacation
yeah just say that carefully yeah
uh that one uh didn't work out he the
their vacation got canceled but so I'm
kind of bummed I didn't have anything
that's funny yeah it was a lot of
cutting back and big money and chicken
sitting yeah
laughs
never heard of my life that's too much
that's so great way to go man how's it
feel to be free I remember the day I had
the money to make the last payment I was
at my uh sister's house and I was
driving home and I just laughed the
entire way it felt so good I woke up the
next day and like it was like seeing in
color for the first time it was just so
it was so amazing that's cool you ever
go back in debt now
what do you tell people the key to
getting out is
so I mean make the plan work the plan
it's not as there's no secrets to paying
off debt I mean so what really was it
for me was knowing why you want to do it
because sacrificing as much as I did
freaking sucked it was I mean there's it
was tough a lot of times and there were
moments where I wanted to backpedal but
I would stop and close my eyes and
visualize different points of what I
wanted my life to look like
being debt free how it was going to feel
when you got here no I picture it myself
on this stage several times to kind of
help get me through yeah pictured myself
like at different stages in my life what
that looked like and that was enough to
snap me back into my
yeah was that your why looking at the
future self right yeah future carrot
thing
yep out there very well done all right
who are your biggest cheerleaders so um
Kenyan and Chris um my mentors they
actually got onto your stuff about a
decade ago
um and went through the baby steps and
they are they're they're living like no
one else right now and they came and
visited you um my mom who's here today
my parents my family
um all my friends I would post updates
on Instagram and people would message me
and say holy crap this is incredible I'm
so happy for you
um a lot of people I also want to give a
special shout out to my um Grandma Jan
she is someone I mean you talk about
people who live and give like no one
else like she is amazing she's always
been very uh open with her time and her
money and just her resources her network
and everything so yeah she's kind of a
great model for me very cool way to go
Jared we're proud of you man great job
great job very good job hey we've got
the live and give bundle for you The
Total Money Makeover book The Baby Steps
millionaires book both number one best
sellers and of course a Financial Peace
University one year membership if you've
not been through it go through it or any
of those give them away read them
whatever you want to do they're for you
just to say thank you and to say we're
proud of you and thanks for hanging out
with us here today in Nashville well
done sir thank you good good one
congratulations thank you amazing
Jarrett from Atlanta 37 000 paid off in
19 months making 52 to 60. count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one oh Dad
friends
yeah yeah
[Music]
I didn't know you could buy one taco
that's awesome no it's like it's a
a coupon it's a coupon I know but I mean
no you're joking like you're like oh I'm
just like wow one taco no
self-discipline too yeah
very cool very good stuff what a great
great story what a great young man very
neat open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five thank you for
jumping in America we're glad you're
with us Sal is with us in New York City
hi Sal how are you
I'm serendi how are you better than we
deserve what's up
I moved to uh USA about five years ago
from Pakistan
um when I moved here I had nothing like
I literally moved here with like a
thousand dollars
um and now you know I I made my way up
um I now make about 150 000 a year wow
um but I took my wife's uh student that
uh student loan uh student debt whatever
you call that I just don't get that
um it's for 23 000 and then I took some
advice from broke people and I bought a
car and my total debt right now is forty
five thousand
um I will be paying off that debt very
aggressively I think I should be done
with that by the end of 2023 but I feel
like I'm really late in the game to
building Wells 39 years old oh you're
ancient how are you getting around I
mean 39. you got a wheelchair yet
um I mean you sound like my dad right
now but uh
Sal you're good I understand I
understand because if you run the
numbers out you're like oh my gosh if I
started this at 20 how much further
ahead I would be if I started at 30 I'm
at 40 am I gonna no there's plenty of
time you got a lot of times a Time Sal
and Sal you're only going to be making
more and with no debt you're gonna have
more income to throw at investing and to
be Building Wealth you're gonna be
totally fine if you got the curve from
one thousand dollars to one hundred and
fifty thousand in five years in America
I think you're gonna be okay
you're amazing that is a very that is
very good to hear from you yeah you're
amazing you're gonna you're gonna get
there my friend now we have a heart
breakout sorry Sal yeah absolutely so
great job though we got commercials
coming in on us brother sorry about that
but we I know you can do it you're on
track you're doing everything right hold
on we're going to send you a Total Money
Makeover book to give you the exact
steps
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Rachel Cruz Ramsey personality is my
co-host today
news headline popping up here the
Supreme Court said it will hear
arguments in February in a case
challenging the Biden administration's
student loan debt relief program but the
Supreme Court kept in place a lower
appeals courts injunction that prevents
the program from taking effect for now
the plan is estimated costs 400 billion
President Joe Biden the plan begins with
the administration agreed to extend a
pause so the Supreme Court has today
agreed to hear the lower courts uh or
the case in the lower court to prevent
the student loan forgiveness program
from going through the Biden
Administration and that's going to
happen in February so there's still two
more months of until it gets there yeah
and nothing is going to happen until
then yeah and also of course the Biden
Administration you guys are aware this
is extended to what May or June the um
no interest so you can go in your
student loan paid off really this is the
time to get it paid off yeah and this is
going to be drug out for years because
no matter what the Supreme Court rules
it's also going to end up in Congress
because if the Supreme Court rules that
uh that the Biden Administration can go
ahead the Republican control Congress is
going to pass a bill to stop it
yeah and so you're you can just count on
this this thing going back and forth
this ping pong and again
we've said since the beginning of time
don't wait on someone else to fix your
life
you don't wait on the government don't
wait on the Biden Administration don't
wait on the courts don't wait on the
Republicans to fix your life you need to
go fix your life and that includes you
paying off your student loan debt which
is by the way your student loan debt not
mine
and I'm a taxpayer and if it is Forgiven
and paid by the taxpayers that means I
paid off your student loan debt I resent
that
I do I shouldn't have to do that and a
guy who's a welder and a guy who's a
truck driver and this gentleman I just
met who's a police officer uh yeah they
shouldn't have to pay off your student
loan debt
um that's just there's it didn't occur
to anybody that that was wrong but
that's wrong
you know a guy who's working he's got up
here on the building working
construction right now hanging steel up
there up on top of the hill for a
master's degree for paying for a
master's degree with somebody in a
left-handed puppetry who's uh you know
yeah it's just wrong it's just wrong
y'all all right Gregory is in Las Vegas
Nevada hi Gregory welcome to the Ramsey
Show
hi Dave and Rachel how are you folks
better than we deserve how can we help
uh so I I just want to say I had the
chance to speak with you guys here in
Las Vegas a few months ago and it's a
pleasure to speak to you folks again
well thank you how can we help so uh
here's my situation uh I am 29 years old
I'm single no kids I'm a motorcycle
police officer here in Las Vegas uh last
December I was in a pretty substantial
work related motorcycle accident and I
am receiving a workers comp settlement
for it's going to be estimated for about
240 000 to 260 000 wow are you okay
um for the most part yes I have a bunch
of residual pains and aches I was in and
out of surgeries and physical therapy
for the past year or so tractions in my
back broken wrist and arm and uh tore up
my knee and pretty good so I'm happy to
be alive though yeah bad wreck
wow yeah I'm sorry man um yeah so and it
happened and I encourage everybody to be
safe out there amen but uh but uh now
I'm happy to be back at work now and uh
doing my old job so you're on the bike
again
uh yes sir uh that was my that was my
big goal to get back up on the
motorcycle and show myself I wasn't
afraid of it
so I mean get back to work is awesome
getting back on that bike scared the
crap out of me okay wow that's
impressive dude okay so how can we help
you today
um I have been uh soliciting advice from
uh some good good uh friend and
financial Savvy family members about
what to do with my uh my settlement
money here and obviously my first
thought was to just go straight into
baby step seven pay off the mortgage and
everything I'm locked in at a two and a
half percent uh on a 15-year fixed rate
mortgage I have about two hundred
thousand dollars left on it so it would
be enough to just uh just wipe off that
mortgage completely but family argues
that I could put it into even just a CD
at four and a half percent and uh get a
return on that and just that would pay
for a good chunk of the mortgage
throughout the year but obviously I want
to give something and um you know pay
off stuff and I that's my only debt left
so I was just wanting some Uncle Dave
advice
okay
um Gregory how long have you been
listening to the show
I've been here uh about four or five
years and I and I know exactly what you
say what exactly what you're gonna say
but okay you know I I feel so what am I
doing some firsthand what am I gonna
conversation write a check today or when
I get the settlement ding ding
okay now can you articulate why your
relative is wrong
well I I look at it a few ways with them
they are I mean based on their four
years of listening to this show
can you say why we would say your
relative is wrong I guess it's a better
way of saying it
okay
well the data points
after we talked to ten thousand one
hundred sixty seven millionaires for the
largest study of millionaires ever done
not your relative we didn't talk to your
relative by the way
um we talked to millionaires
and um
precise the number of them that said I
used the money from my mortgage
instead of paying off my mortgage I used
that money to invest and that made me
wealthy the number of millionaires has
said that they use that technique was
precisely zero
not one right
not one said I became Rich because I
Arbitrage my freaking house
I borrowed on my home and invested at a
greater rate which is arbitrage okay
it's the definition of the term and not
one of the wealthy people say they do
that the only people that talk about
that are people that talk about Theory
and in the real world though the rest of
us out here live in a world of risk
you've just about got killed on a dead
gun motorcycle you know what risk looks
like okay right and and risk is we don't
know what's going to happen and
um we do know that we've also done
research that 100 of the foreclosures
occur on a home with a mortgage
so when you borrow money you increase
your risk and risk was not in
mathematically in the formula that
you're relative used
right you are taking on more risk and so
if you were to adjust for risk and put
the money into a 10 investment you would
break even
oh by the way on the 10 investment you
also have to pay taxes so you adjust for
risk and taxes uh your 10 is going to
start looking a lot like four
and you're going to be back down to
mortgage rates again and so it just
doesn't work and and that is born out
then in the actual practical fact that
people who actually do build wealth not
those that discuss theories about
Building Wealth but the ones that
actually do it use their most powerful
wealth building tool
which is not borrowed money
it is their income
to become wealthy and when you don't
have a house payment sir you are in a
position to invest very aggressively to
be outrageously generous
um take a mortgage payment once you pay
off this house with this money with this
money this is just this is money that
you say he's 29 years old yep and then
run out that mortgage payment for the
next 20 years
in an investment in what you could make
investing that mortgage payment versus
putting this money quote unquote in a CD
yeah that one thing I'll make the one
thing will make you mean that and
Gregory no one's accounting for and
people don't talk about this because
it's not going to be in the numbers but
there is something about when you don't
owe anyone anything John deloney talks
about this you have autonomy like you
when you don't owe anyone anything you
want the ability to do whatever you want
but whenever you hand a little bit of
your future over even a mortgage and a
mortgage is the one type of debt we
don't yell at people for but if you have
the money to pay it off and not to have
a bank have any say in your future there
is a level where your mind your soul
rests and you sleep at night when you
don't owe anyone anything and again
that's that's more of the emotional side
of this that is not put into percentages
and interest rates but it is it's very
real it's very very real
and swap Proverbs says the rich rules
over the poor and the borrower is slave
to the lender you don't run into
generous slaves you don't run into
wealthy slaves
and this is the this is the principle
that we're operating on and it really
does work so I appreciate the good
intentions of your relative who is wrong
but they are ding ding wrong this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
ER you can find all of our shows with
the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS of
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where that is done cash is
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice I am Dave Ramsey your
host Rachel Cruz number one best-selling
author many times over Ramsay
personality my daughter is my co-host
today as we ask answer your questions
about your life and your money we help
people
build wealth do work that they love and
create amazing relationships Sam is with
us Sam is in Salt Lake City Hi Sam how
are you
better than I deserve Dave how are you
just the same sir what's up
hey so I'm on baby step two I'm getting
out of debt and but that came a
promotion in my job
and with that promotion they gave me a
vehicle for personal conveyance and they
say that the vehicle will cost the
company about eleven thousand dollars a
year so I was wondering what your
thoughts are on if I give the vehicle
back and then just ask for that eleven
thousand dollars in the form of a race
okay well
uh I take it you have another car
yeah all right and what do you make
uh this year I'm on track to make about
80
000. cool what do you do
I'm a heavy equipment mechanic
okay so this is a truck
yeah it's well I have my work truck that
I'm in right now
and then they're giving me this just to
get to the shop in the morning and then
to drive back home because this truck is
outrageous to be driving an hour and a
house and fuel every day
there's a big commute
yeah that you have okay yeah I drive
about an hour each way to get to work to
pick up your work truck
yeah
okay
um
surprised I didn't just let you take
your work truck is it super expensive to
operate
it's about three miles per gallon
about six dollars a gallon here it's you
know okay so you make eighty thousand
you're on the road all the time but not
with this truck
if you have an hour commute how many
miles is it to your office from your
home
that's about 65 miles okay so let's call
it 150 miles a day
and
um
yes you're putting a lot of miles on
your car just getting to work you
realize you're yeah you realize the
value of the vehicle that you're driving
is being destroyed by the miles you're
putting on it
well I mean it's it's paid off as 200
000 miles on it right now and I figure I
can at least get 350 out of that before
it's done
foreign
the math I'm trying to run in my head is
are you spending eleven thousand dollars
a year in Lost vehicle
value you're not with driving this whole
beat up or not all beat up but there's a
high mileage old car you're not because
that car's not got a lot of value to
start with but if you're taking a a 11
000 value or twenty thousand dollar
value car you're cutting the value on it
substantially every year just with your
commute because of the miles you're
putting on it does that make sense
yeah and I mean I bought this car for
five thousand dollars I know I know but
I'm just saying if you were driving a 20
000 car it changes the equation that's
what that so I'm trying to run the math
in my head here
um
you know you're not really saving
anything on depreciation the gas is more
expensive in the truck are they
Furnishing you gas
dude you can't I mean with this you're
burning a bunch of gas
yeah
you need to add up what the gasp is
worth
yeah I did that actually the other day
Okay and the truck is about
260 dollars a week that they'd have to
pay for fuel and then my cost for fuel
is about a hundred and eleven dollars a
week
okay so half yeah all right and where
the car is not worth much right now I
just figured it was trying to appreciate
that much yeah so it's the switch and
that
um if your car lays down
you're a mechanic you'll get it back up
uh
hmm
so 100 bucks a week five thousand
dollars a year
for a raise of 11 000 a year Well I
wouldn't just turn it in
the only way I would turn it in is if
you got eleven thousand dollars
yeah and that's why I was gonna I wanted
to get your guys in stock because when
you divide that up hourly you're not
you're not picking up as much money
you're picking up three or four hundred
bucks a month by driving your car
versus driving their truck and them
Furnishing the gas
so you're not you're not picking up tons
of money here with eleven thousand
dollar raise and not having the truck
um
but how many times how many times last
year did your car lay down on you
zero
I mean I'd keep up on preventive
maintenance you know I always have good
tires on it you don't have you don't
have any trouble with weather in Salt
Lake then
no it's all highway miles so it's all
just you know yeah they keep the freeway
clear and I know how to drive yeah yeah
I mean I I get exactly where you are
um if we added in uh a different
situation with a more expensive vehicle
and some other things it really wouldn't
make sense it would make more sense to
keep the truck for 11 000. usually it's
more than that I'm not sure they're
going to give you eleven thousand
dollars to the truck because they
probably already owned the truck
no this is a brand new truck that
they're still making payments on that
they bought for you
yeah
yeah
and they have to sell it and give you
eleven thousand dollars I you know pass
it on to the next person in line for a
trout yeah okay how big a company
uh we got this is so interesting
we got like 20 some odd Vehicles like
light duty pickups on the road and then
we have you know a bunch of heavy
equipment and a couple semis and dump
trucks and stuff like that okay all
right uh
interesting well I I
don't know if they're going to do it
because I I think their mindset is they
want you in a reliable vehicle yeah and
they see this as having blessed you you
need to be very careful with your tone
and your language that you come off as
very grateful for the truck
I'm really grateful for it I think I can
come out a little bit better if you paid
me eleven thousand dollars a year
instead of instead and I would rather
have that would you consider that I'm
grateful though either way be careful
that's the way it needs to sound okay it
doesn't need to sound like hey man
rather not have the truck
yeah that sounds like after they after I
just handed your keys to a new truck
that sounds kind of ungrateful
yeah so yeah um you know things like
think like if you were on the other side
of this desk how you would feel right
yeah and that'll help you form your
sentences on bringing this up but I
don't think it's the end of the world
either way neither one of these
decisions are going to make you rich or
poor
um but it's an interesting discussion to
talk through because company cars
um
when they take away the company car and
give you a car allowance you almost
always lose yeah in that scenario and um
most of you out there and because
they're usually running your butt over
the road in that company car in this
case you know it's it's just your
commute so it's a lot of different
variables in this case this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
number one best-selling author Ramsey
personality Rachel Cruz is my co-host
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five if you've
gone through Financial Peace University
chances are it's because someone lit a
fire under you mom or dad your pastor
offered it at church a friend that
wouldn't shut up and made you go through
so you finally took the glass you
started working the baby steps and now
everything has changed you changed your
entire future you're able to build
wealth be generous got out of debt
maybe you need to be the fire that's lit
under somebody
you could give someone you care about
Financial Peace University and share the
same hope you've discovered
Christmas coming it's a great way to
give gift giving it's actually a gift
that is usable and that does matter
and when you give Financial Peace
University as a gift they get more than
just a course they're going to get the
premium version of every dollar so they
can start living on a budget and even
join the growing in on the group calls
with our team of financial coaches so
this Christmas give the people you care
about a gift that actually matters hope
freedom
Financial Peace University to give that
as a gift go to ramseysolutions.com give
FPU
ramseysolutions.com
give FPU
Miriam Is Well With Us in Tulsa Oklahoma
hi Miriam welcome to the Ramsay show
hi thank you so much for taking my call
I'm a huge fan I never miss a podcast
well thank you very much how can we help
okay so my husband just got a different
job
um it's actually with the same company
it's just a different job and a perk of
this job is
um a house so he's going to be taking
care of a ranch and there's a house on
the ranch that we're going to be moving
into my question is
um when it comes to of course we'll be
able to live there until retirement time
but we'll never own this house so my
question is how do I pay for a house at
retirement so once we retire
um we'll either have money to buy or to
build
um
like that something like that
well if you don't have rent could you
just pay yourself rent
yeah so like a quarter of our take-home
pay would be about fifteen hundred
dollars so I'm planning on doing
something with that fifteen hundred
dollars I just don't know where to put
it to make the best
um investment for us but with the
intentions of it going to a house so I
want to be able to get to it good I
would just sit down with a smartvester
pro and pick out some mutual funds and
have that fifteen hundred dollars
automatically drafted out of your
checking account going into an
investment every month
okay and then just I would just nickname
that mutual fund uh house fund
okay awesome that sounds great yeah um I
have another question if you have time
okay
okay so um obviously once we sell our
house move into this new house we're
going to be on baby steps four five and
six and
um my question is college so
um
my son is almost 12.
I don't see him going to college but
I want to be able to
um since we are able to financially help
him I want to do it if he chooses to go
I just don't feel like he will choose to
go so I guess my question is the way I
understand 529 is it has to be used for
college and I know you can use it for
nieces and nephews but he's he's the
youngest and so I guess my question
would be
is there somewhere that I can like put
money back for that would it be the same
kind of thing like a mutual fund yeah if
I didn't want to do it I took it and I'm
just taking an investment in your name
and then if you choose to give some of
your money to your son at that point the
only difference is that investment's
taxable
and then a 529 it's green attack and a
529 is growing tax-free
yeah but he thought did I understand
right that if he chooses not to go to
college and I'm already interested in a
529 yeah it would be stuck there yeah
yeah I mean for Education you could use
it your husband could use it any of the
kids could use it you know extended
family can use it but nobody else and so
yeah it could get stuck there it's not
stuck I mean you don't lose the money
but you would you you know you would be
taxed and penalized both when you took
the money out and so if you want to just
go and pay the taxes now it's not that
big a difference but it does help uh if
you know you're going to college it's a
smart thing to do a 529 but if you're
pretty sure it's not then I would just
have money in your name it's just your
money and then you can decide what to do
with your money later uh again the same
you know nickname one house fund and the
other one college fund but they're just
nicknames they're both just mutual funds
in your name really when you get
technically to it you can do it you
could you can change the name to boat
fund if you want to I don't care right
Bahamas that sounds great Bahamas fund
that's one you know that's yeah um Cabo
you know I don't know or even in some
parents right they've done where they
put money aside like an enema and then
when the kid turns 18 21 it's there or
21. that yeah if you want to just put
money in his name you can do that
um and it will be taxed only at his rate
which is zero until it gets substantial
money in there
so but that's just money in his name
that's how we did our kids college
because 529s were not there was no such
thing when our kids when we were saving
for our kids college
and so Rachel Rachel and Denise and
Daniel all had money in their name in an
utma and um you know that money when
they were 21 just transferred to them it
was just their money
that depends on what you want how much
you want to end up with I mean in age 12
you got six years so I mean um and I
would kind of I mean you know if you're
not going to do the college funds still
I would still save as if you were and
almost kind of just follow that plan and
say okay how much would it be if he was
going to go to a just a four-year state
school you know and just like kind of
let that be the range because if not and
he doesn't go that that money could
still be used for him to further any
type of training uh trade school he
could use that to to go forward in his
future even if it's not just a
Traditional School exactly and any lump
sum you got from the sale of your house
can also be added to your mutual fund
for your future house fund too by the
way just to add to this discussion open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five Shelley is in Coeur
d'Alene Idaho hi Shelly how are you
I'm good how are you better than I
deserve how can we help
my main question is this I'm a retired
police officer
officer I was hired due to Medical
injuries that occurred on duty so my
retirement is tax free
I do have 457b as well so I currently
work at a second career selling real
estate and when I retire so now I have
to pay taxes but once I retire from this
job and my only income is my pension I
will not have to pay I will have no tax
basis so my question is should I be
um
putting 15 into some other kind of
account from my real estate money sure
or should I it would that just be like a
traditional rather than the Roth which
would no it needs to be wrong now and
not later yeah it used to be a Roth
you got taxes even though I don't pay
taxes on it when I take it out later
right you want tax-free later on the
Roth it's much better growth regardless
of your pension situation it doesn't
affect the Roth calculation how old are
you
56. okay so you're probably let's say
you end up with a hundred thousand bucks
on your Roth and it grows to 200 you're
probably not going to touch it you're
probably going to live off the pension
it's just going to sit there and grow
tax-free which is awesomeness okay
okay so yeah I mean it's just a wealth
building tool it's not a mandatory so I
have money to eat at at retirement you
got money to eat at retirement you're
past that part but this is just a wealth
building tool at this point
all right so a traditional where you pay
taxes on it at which law would not would
not be more beneficial yeah because 10
to 15 years from now when you pull the
money out
90 of the money that will be in that
account will be growth
it will not be what you have put in and
for all of that growth to be taxed then
so that you get a little bit of a tax
break now is a bad trade
okay well good I hadn't done that yet
because I couldn't decide and I kept
waiting for someone else to call and ask
the question and nobody did and you're
the one
oh Magic you're the one that got through
that's important stuff right so that
this idea that that grows tax-free
[Music]
and I just have to pay taxes on that
when you take it out that's when you're
a hit so take the pain now pay taxes on
it before you put it in and then that
way gross tax-free you you you avoid
taxes on a dollar now and pay taxes on
nine dollars later yep yep or you avoid
taxes on nine dollars later and pay
taxes on a dollar now that's the
trade-off this is the Ramsey Show
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
Rachel Cruz Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America we are so glad you are here in
the lobby of Ramsey Solutions on the
debt free stage Thomas and Emily are
with us welcome guys hey Dave hey thank
you good to have you where do y'all live
Jacksonville Florida very cool well
welcome all the way to Nashville to do a
debt free scream how much have you paid
off
so we ended up paying uh 220
525 whoa love it and how long did this
take uh that actually ended up taking
two years five months in one week all
right and your range of income during
that two years five months in one week
went from uh 125
000 uh going up to two hundred and
twenty thousand and just about at this
point we're about two hundred thousand
wow what do you guys do for a living
um I am actually a real estate agent
and I do
um at least mobile offices so anytime
you see a construction site kind of
start up oh yeah that's uh something I
end up doing cool awesome very good good
for you guys well both both good
businesses for sure excellent well done
what kind of debt was your 221 000.
it was our mortgage yeah
the house yes look at you too what's the
house worth
um probably about 400. I love it how
much you guys got in retirement
uh I don't know like 200. yeah that's
good way to go so you're most of the way
to being millionaires already I hope so
that's pretty cool how old are y'all
um I am 30. and I'm 36. I love it wow
not even 40 years old in a paid for
house worth 400 Grand how in the world
does that feel oh my gosh
but we own the entire house the bedroom
the kitchen we just counted down the
rooms like okay now we own this room now
we own this room so the biggest
excitement was uh was getting the lawn
the last piece oh yeah we got the dirt
in the case of Jacksonville the sand so
I got to ask you guys because you paid
off your house we've had a few calls
this show people they're like okay we
have the money to pay off our house but
I feel like I should invest it and make
more money and stretch out the more you
know they they're rationalizing it with
math just tell America if you could go
back would you keep the cash and just
put it in a good investment or would you
still pay off the house how tell me
about the feelings that you have around
this pay it off oh yeah without a shadow
of a doubt you pay off the house knowing
that there's there's nobody that that
you owe a dollar to is a big win oh yeah
there's no feeling like I don't care if
we had a hundred thousand dollars more
in retirement it feels way better to own
the house oh it's so good yeah I love it
just the weight is off completely free
yes completely free congratulations you
guys thank you thank you so huge so well
done oh so very well done
congratulations so two years and how
long you've been married uh four and a
half years yeah okay so uh 18 months 24
months into your marriage something woke
you up what was the wake-up call my wife
yeah
it was about uh actually about this time
in 2018 we visited you at your old place
and we said we're gonna be back we'll be
back when the house is paid off and we
closed on the house in February of 2020
and right in time for a quarantine oh
yeah literally the week before
everything shut down we signed the
papers oh my gosh and I said well we
can't be Liars to Dave so we just
started paying it off as fast as we
possibly could we know that most people
pay it off we got a 15-year mortgage and
you always say pay it off in seven we're
like we can beat that and so we're like
okay let's do three and a half years I'm
like we can beat that and then with
three years and we ended up doing in
just under two and a half years yeah and
then you look out there and all that's
left is the lawn yeah
absolutely
amazing buy that I'll buy Park Place
exactly okay so was it hard what was the
tuna if yours like for you guys oh kind
of tough it was a lot of you know we
can't do this we can't do that it was a
lot of
limiting ourselves but we just kept our
eye on the prize and we knew as soon as
we made that last mortgage payment we
can do whatever we wanted and he can
have as many coffees as he wanted giving
up copies was hard
but it's it's totally worth it yeah yeah
great job so what do you tell people the
key is
to getting out of debt yeah so I would
say the the biggest thing is to set a
plan a goal
um and do everything to achieve that I
mean because at the end of the day if
you start veering off from that goal it
it really does extend the time and what
we ended up realizing was
as we continued to push towards that it
went from as Emily said 15 to five years
to even less than that for three years
to no two and a half yeah exactly just
start you just have to start you can't
put it off you just say this is what
we're doing this is our plan we're
starting and nothing's going to get in
our way you know I I remember the
Sensation that it's weird that
the closer you get the more you realize
this is really going to happen and the
more intense you get the deeper you
sacrifice it's like you get through you
get weirder you know with your
sacrifices as you get closer because
you're like I want to get this done yeah
it's like gamified you know yes whenever
we were going to make the last payment I
called time at work I'm like can I just
pay it off like can I just make the
paint last payment and I'm like I just I
can't wait until you get home even I
just I just want to do it and so I just
I called the bank I'm like whatever it
is pay it off do it now and we paid it
off and I called him up I said we we own
it it's ours just like that just like
that yep so what's the first big thing
you're going to do now that you're rich
ery vacation plan for our five-year
anniversary
so we're going to do that what
we're gonna go to good again
we love it so we'll be there next summer
and then we're gonna buy some investment
properties hopefully and just make sure
we're set up for life and be able to
live and give even after we're not here
anymore we want to make sure that our
Legacy lives on and we're able to give
to other people wow you guys are amazing
I'm so proud of you okay now that you
got weirder and weirder as we said as
you get towards the goal uh people make
fun of anybody look at you we give you
the side eye
absolutely there have been
there been the question you know hey why
why do you feel the need to do that and
I mean especially as as you kind of
referenced how young we are it really
was that ask of saying you know hey
you're going to understand when we have
the ability to retire at an early age so
that's that's kind of the next goal at
least the way I'm doing it yeah
freedom you have the ability to save and
invest and do things faster earlier all
of it because you have your income you
have your income you have to do whatever
you want yeah that's awesome you guys
very cool well done well done well done
well done who are your biggest
cheerleaders
um probably I have to give a huge shout
out to my sister Lindsay and her husband
Wesley they are huge fans of yours they
you know she got me started on it she
they were even going to go on your
cruise for their honeymoon they're
Obsessed
the cruise the pandemic Cruise
was cursed but she got me started on it
and she was our cheerleader the whole
time I mean I would call her all the
time like we made another payment we're
this this much closer and she was she
was my first call whenever well after I
told him yeah after that then I called
my sister I was like we did it we're
done and so she her and her husband have
just been amazing that's wonderful
that's a gift too to have family
celebrate with you yeah you gotta have
people on your team that are going yeah
especially family sister like that
that's great very very cool all right
we've got the live and give bundle for
you that's The Total Money Makeover book
and the baby steps millionaires book
because that's the next chapter in your
story you're just a minute and a half
away from that so well done and of
course the Financial Peace University
membership and you you keep some of that
you give some of that whatever you want
to do with it and it's our gift to you
and saying thank you for being here well
done we're very proud of you Thomas and
Emily Jacksonville Florida 221 000 paid
off in two years five months in one week
making 125 to 120. count it down let's
hear a debt-free scream three two one
we're dead free
[Applause]
[Music]
one whoa man 30 years old 36 years old
eight four four hundred thousand dollar
house in Jacksonville Florida amazing
mic drop this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
blessed is the one who perseveres under
trial
because having stood the test that
person will receive the crown of life
that the Lord has promised to those who
love him
Celine Dion said life imposes things on
you that you can't control but you still
have the choice of how you're going to
live through this
thanks for a Celine Dion quote wow look
at the look at the drama in that quote
wow
it's a great quote open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Daniel is with us in San Jose California
hi Daniel what's up hey Dave how's your
day going better than we deserve sir how
can we help
yeah so my wife and I got married
earlier this year congratulations
thank you I work at a church and she has
her own hair salon company and we live
in California and it is crazy here
financially
um we live in a two-bedroom apartment
cost us two thousand dollars a month
and my question is as a two-parter first
is we'd love to start a family but we
don't know when the right time is for
that financially to grow a family and
two we're actually looking to move to
Tennessee
because of that so first question when's
the right time for us to start a family
in two
um should we move to Tennessee if it's
or move to another state if we can't
handle it financially
well I'll say number two there's a lot
of California people here in Nashville
these days that were that we're meeting
and that are my neighbors we have entire
California refugee camps in Tennessee
so no people do move for the you know
what exactly what you're talking about
though for the financial reasons to have
a better quality of life because you
just mathematically get more other
places than you can wear real estate and
everything's more expensive so naturally
you know you're gonna well it's gonna be
it's not just California dude you're in
freaking San Jose my God I mean that's
like some of the most expensive real
estate on the planet
you picked out the most expensive place
to live other than maybe Manhattan and
well this is San Jose I mean it's yeah
so how close is Silicon Valley so there
you go oh okay yeah all right so wow
part of San Francisco
um but number one
yeah I mean honestly we don't tell
people that you have to be debt free or
fill in the blank to get married to have
kids I mean you still are going to live
your life uh obviously things are a
little bit you breathe easier if you
have money saved I mean these simple
things but we don't have a hard and fast
rule of are you financially ready to
have a kid or not I mean if that's what
you guys want to do and start a family
then yeah I would I would start one but
um but just knowing that
um you know the more financially secure
you guys are meaning you don't have
debts uh you have money saved in the
bank all of that it's just gonna make
that transition less stressful if money
isn't a huge play in it now there's only
one choice that you've got that's a
better that's better than the choice you
made to marry her and that's babies
babies are awesome
amen get babies they're awesome okay
it's that simple all right and now the
question is then you know how do you do
that in a way that doesn't just
completely freak you guys out well
you've got to do a little bit of
thinking about the money yeah but
there's not a thing that says you know
you have to have this and this and this
before you can afford to have children
that's crap then to start with they're
not that expensive they do cost I mean
but it's it's not people act like it's
two hundred thousand dollars or
something it's you know it's some
diapers and some formula and you have to
pay the pediatrician's Porsche payment
that's it I mean but then when you this
did you say
but but if you know Daniel if your wife
works though you know you think about
child care I mean there's some I mean
you got to think through your life so
that naturally is going to be more
expensive but if you're going to move to
another state
and you're going to have a kid
um you know in the next 12 months then
you need to decide which one to do first
I wouldn't try to do both at the same
time they're both going to cost you you
know what two to five thousand dollars
to make a move two to five thousand
dollars to depending on I mean if you do
a cheap move and you throw some stuff in
a U-Haul if is there still any U-Hauls
left in California but if there's any
left you could get on that and take it
out of there and or get you a pods right
and um pods people are our pods our
sponsor will help you and you know get
moved anyway and but it's not super
duper killer expensive and neither is a
child if you've got health insurance
and so um you know but I wouldn't want
to do both in the same number one you
don't want to move with a pregnant lady
that's a bad idea okay so let's uh you
know let's think about that and then on
number two let's think well it's not
it's not fair to her I mean you got
enough to do you know so we moved three
weeks after I had a baby and I was able
to sit on the couch hold a baby and just
tell everyone what I wanted to so that
was actually tell everyone where to go
that's exactly what happened yeah
so yeah I just had a baby three weeks
ago
no those are just big Life Changes
Daniel they're just big life changes
that naturally are going to cause stress
it's not I mean you're just naturally
going to be a little bit more on edge
when given a choice I wouldn't do them
all at once yeah
yeah
so I mean I I would do one and then the
other and how long have you guys been
married Daniel you just got married the
first year
yeah about uh nine months okay and uh
it's been the best nine months ever oh
Daniel or so it's a good guy sounds nice
you're gonna be great Levi's with us in
Tulsa Oklahoma hi Levi what's up
hey how you doing appreciate your time
sure how can we help
yeah my biggest question is basically
how long is too long for staying house
poor
okay give us some more some more details
leviation I make about 60 000 a year as
a mail carrier and my wife just recently
we had a baby about 10 months ago
congratulations and
um we have been able to put him in a
child care with my family so we haven't
had to spend any money on that for now
but we my wife has decided she wants to
stay home and spend more time with the
baby and so that's
cut her sixty thousand dollar salary
completely out of our equation and we
have a twelve thirteen hundred dollar a
month payment for our house so with just
my salary that pushes us
out of the comfortable range yeah
well you know and what I don't want to
do is sign up for indefinite
so indefinite sounds like she's going to
stay at home and you're going to be a
mail carrier making 60k you're stuck
this is not sustainable because you
don't have an exit plan from house poor
if you've got a plan you got a plan and
you hold your breath meaning you're
going to do something to double your
income in the next two years or three
years then we hold our breath and get
through that right
right but 10 years from now you don't
want to be signed up for this exact same
trip
no no
the biggest problem is is I really like
my job it's going to increase but you
know federal government it's not going
to increase on what I need not much soon
no I mean your income went from 120 to
60. yeah your income went from 120 to
60. we have to have a path to get it
back to 100 or we've got to have a
different house
yeah and you know even in Tulsa Oklahoma
houses are we would be either renting in
a dumpy part of town or buying in a
dangerous part of town and
not really wanting to do either one of
those you know
it's uh I hate to be the kind of guy
that's like hey we really need you to go
work somewhere
um you know I don't want to look it's a
choice if she wants to be home it's not
going to be in that house or you're
going to change careers
okay
the math just isn't there yeah okay and
no I don't care I don't care personally
which one you do
um but one of you is going to make some
different choices about your career you
or her or we're not going to live in
this house
that that's the thing and so the it's
not how you know and then if you tell me
hey I'm gonna do this thing I'm going to
ramp up and go I'm going to go to code
school and I'm gonna go make 150 000 a
year doing uh Ruby on Rails coding uh
okay and that's going to take me two
years okay we can hold our breath three
years I can do that all right and this
is a values conversation for you guys
for you and your wife to talk through
because in order for her to stay home
which is great be very delicate P.S when
you're talking to her she has a baby
less than a year and she wants to be
with the baby okay so be very delicate
when you're communicating with her but
to be but like like if that is worth it
to y'all then living in a small smaller
house is worth it it's a value system of
your family but it's gonna have to
sacrifice and you guys can do that it
might be further out of town yeah the
way that works that's right that's right
something like that that puts this hour
of the Ramsey Show in the books we'll be
back with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus
hey it's Rachel Cruz co-host on the
Ramsay show if you want to do your debt
free stream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com set free screen we'd
love for you to come to Nashville and
tell Dave your story that's
ramsesolutions.com debt free screen
[Music]